I do believe that just detected a
comment section going straight to hell
so first off I want to say the response
to the video I made with my thoughts on
Jodie Whittaker being cast as the doctor
has been kind of unprecedented it's been
phenomenal honestly in terms of both the
the viewership the general reaction and
the comment section well mostly by and
large the comment sections have been
actually really interesting for me to
watch when they remained respectful
unfortunately they don't always but this
isn't really a comment response video
I'm not quite so self indulgent has to
get into those quite yet but um I do
want to address something that I kept
seeing get brought up in the comments
because I feel like it's something that
is not only not a great comparison but
making the comparison especially the way
people do as like it closes the book on
argument it is kind of distracting
something that I saw repeatedly brought
up by people who take at some degree of
issue with Jodie Whittaker playing the
doctor specifically in terms of the
doctrinal longer being portrayed by a
man is comparing it to the 2016 a reboot
of ghostbusters and I kind of want to
address that because like I said I don't
I'm not sure they've completely thought
this through and I just there's
something I just feel they need to point
out in the hope of calming some people
down a little bit now I again do have
concerns about Jodie Whittaker as the
doctor
I'm also very hopeful I'm certainly not
abandoning the show or anything like
that I might come back to that point as
well but I do have points of concern I
have expressed them in two videos now so
I'm not going to rehash all that but the
comparison to Ghostbusters 2016 doesn't
work for one mr. reason that was a
reboot now here's something about a
reboot
a reboot in a way kind of erases the old
film now not in any true practical way
as people who are often in favor of
these kinds of changes love to point out
no one's coming and taking away your old
versions of ghostbusters you just watch
that and let us do this well that's true
but at the same time what a reboot does
say is in this continuity nothing that
you loved about the original films
happened it doesn't count anymore if we
get to make any sequels to this we're
not going to acknowledge this and if we
have our way and this is successful
Ghostbusters will now mean this and it
will no longer mean the thing that it
used to be that you used to love now
that's not unique to ghostbusters that's
actually inherent in most reboots so the
reason it stuck out with ghostbusters so
much is that functionally story-wise
pretty much on every level there was no
need for it to be a reboot they would
have taken minimal tinkering with the
story to just have it be a continuation
not completely wipe out the old
continuity and then not piss off a whole
chunk of fans who often got loved would
be unfortunately incredibly loud and
very rude people just going no girls
allowed but their concern was really
over a feeling of legitimate loss
because they were being told that what
they loved doesn't count anymore
and again that's kind of what happens
with a reboot and it stuck out with
ghostbusters because that was and it
would visor reboot the the project may
have had you know it had other issues
going on as well
but I know that there was a whole
contingent of fans who took issue with
that movie not because it was women but
because there was no need for it to
completely erase the film that they
loved I was in that same camp now
ultimately when the film came out I
didn't hate as much as I thought I would
but it also wasn't great it was fine it
just kind of was but I don't want to
dwell too much on that but I just want
to make the point like what regeneration
is or actually more specifically what
regeneration is not is a reboot
regeneration is a wonderful thing that
is truly unique to Doctor Who
now I absolutely understand people who
have concerns about the doctor being
played by a woman as I said I have some
of my own I get people feeling some
degree of loss at the fact that the
doctor will no longer be portrayed by a
man I understand that people who are
making the decision that they will no
longer watch the show because the doctor
is going to be portrayed by a woman I
don't agree with that one but I
understand the root of the sentiment
even if I very surely don't agree with
it and I personally will be watching the
show but what I don't get is people
acting as if Jodie Whittaker playing the
doctor somehow erases the previous
incarnations of the doctor in fact I've
seen some comments where people
basically say that's what it does but it
isn't and again that's part of the
glorious thing about Doctor Who because
of how her generation works not only
does Jodie Whittaker playing the doctor
not erase any previous male version of
the doctor it actually can't exist
without them and I don't just mean in
the sense of all if there wasn't a
original we couldn't be still lesser I
mean gee just narrative Lee she could
not exist without all these previous
incarnations and Doctor Who as a show
has always been very quick to integrate
the past experiences of the doctor so
none of that's going away and more to
the point with something like
ghostbusters if they wanted to make it
male again they were going to have to
rearrange the new thing they just did if
for whatever reason this either doesn't
work or even if it does once she's
decided she's done with the part we can
get a man again we may or may not but
you can get it back so any sense of loss
that you get and one is you're willing
to not abandon the show all together is
going to be temporary now that's not me
minimizing your sense of loss if you are
feeling a sense of loss as the doctor no
longer being male but it's temporary
unless the show gets cancelled which is
the other thing that I'm seeing in the
comments that I really really don't
understand
I understand people who say that they
believe that this move will cause the
show to get canceled I don't agree but
fine I get that that's what you believe
will happen what I don't get is when I
see people who claim to be fans actively
wishing that the show will now fail and
get canceled because of this change I
would say I don't get that but I suppose
I do in the sense of they feel it will
validate their anger at this move but
I'm not sure of the people making that
particular leap like going beyond just
saying I won't watch this but actually
saying I hope the show gets cancelled
which again I know it's happening I'm
seeing it happen in my own comment
section I don't know if they've thought
that thought all the way through because
they're actually actively rooting for
something that they claim to love to die
and I know that I'm the guy who put out
a very ranty video screaming about how I
wanted Warner Brothers DCE you movies to
fail but here's the thing if you stuck
through that video all the way through
and let me get to my final point the
reason I wanted them to fail was so that
they would have to try again and the
reason they would be able to try again
is because the source material the comic
books weren't going anywhere whether the
movies were successful or not there
might be ancillary stuff for Doctor Who
there might be comic books there are
audios or other things but it's a show
first so when you root for the show to
die you're rooting for the source
material to go away you're rooting for
the foundation to end and I don't
understand that I never will and as I
said I do have my concerns with the
doctor no longer being a man but I root
for the show I will always room for this
show this is my favorite show on
television and I will always always tune
in because I want it to be great and
every episode that ever gets made I want
to watch so that I get
to see whether or not it's great and
when it's not great yeah it sucks and if
it ever becomes consistently not great
which I know some people feel under
Martha it did that sucks every new
episode is a chance for it to be great
and that's why I'm always going to come
back now again if you're making the
decision to bail on the show now I
personally don't quite get at least not
giving it a shot to see if it's working
for you but at the very least I would
think that even if you decide to not
watch for as long as Jodie Whittaker is
the doctor that you would still sit back
and go boy I hope it keeps going so that
it can become something that I love
again as opposed to sitting back and
going man I hope that thing that I used
to love dies because it'll validate my
feelings about this particular thing
that I don't think they should have done
so I think that's about it I don't know
if I just said something that was
insightful and helpful or that was
self-indulgent and incendiary and I
suppose the reaction that I get this one
will be my answer so your thoughts on I
guess what I just said
will have yours are your thoughts
continuing to change evolve on the
doctor becoming a woman are now that
we've had you know more time more days
to deal with it is your opinion
softening are you standing your ground
are you more excited are you less
excited whatever your thoughts are and
please keep them respectful I love
seeing discussions between people
disagree as long as no one is you know
shouting obscenities at each other so if
you can keep it civil drop something
down on the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to Like subscribe check me
out on Twitter I council of geeks give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast I
am also one half of the punch like a
girl podcast both of those are available
on iTunes and stitcher and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]